[Music]
well
there's some very interesting news
coming out of china
where they are like this one
portion of china china
um they are saying that they are gonna
ban dog walking and put in place a very
harsh
three-strike penalty system so what
about turtle walker
i don't know can you walk a turtle dogs
for dogs dog
for the coveted periods or just in
general no general it sounds like
it's because of poo poo um well they're
saying that they're
trying to correct uncivilized dog
ownership in urban areas
so the three strikes dog ownership yeah
the three strikes here is um that number
one
would be a warning number two the person
will be fined
the dog owner and for the third offense
guess what put the dog down oh the dog
gets killed
yeah dude they're gonna kill the dog
that's china i've seen some uncivilized
dog ownership in my neighborhood
where you're walking in the middle of
the sidewalk and there's dookie all over
the sidewalk
and nobody cleaned it up like [ __ ]
dicks that's not nice
yeah it's not the dog's fault yeah
there's a house around my block where me
and you were taking a little walk the
other day and it had like three
different signs on their grass that said
please pick up your dog poop and i was
like i was like oh that's a little
excessive until i saw a [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
right by like it was like two feet away
from the side there in spite of the sign
it seems like
dude they do it next to the sign on the
sidewalk
no yeah i mean that's pretty crazy
because i have walked where was it
i don't remember where we were but it
was a different country and we
had to avoid dog [ __ ] like everywhere
almost every other step
i don't remember yeah i don't know it
could be anywhere there's a lot of
irresponsible dog owners because then
we'll look through our nest cameras and
there's
like people walking their doctors on
their phone so their dog takes the [ __ ]
don't even know
no they're pretending like they don't
know maybe yeah as soon as the dog
starts fishing he's like oh i got a text
oh yeah look at me they know because
they don't want to go inside
hello yeah that's true come on
but then but do you guys honestly feel
like this will correct
behavior if they know that their dog is
going to get killed
no i think the owner should die no
that's even because
that'll eliminate the behavior there you
go yeah cause over here like if your dog
gets out
and uh the shelter gets your dog they'll
send you a notice hey if you don't pick
up your dog in seven days we're putting
them down
really so it's not like that's a new
thing by the way because it used to be
in the 90s it was just like your dog
might get killed if you don't find it in
time
yeah but now because of microchipping so
it doesn't seem to like the punishment
doesn't seem too far off but i don't
think it's going to work because it
doesn't really
curb anyone's behavior over here either
yeah
people are commenting on chinese social
media saying like
why on earth would they should be killed
why on earth should they be killed
and then another one says what did the
dogs do wrong and then another one is
like this is
an unscientific and lazy way of dealing
with do you think chad's like um
do you know we used to kill you if you
had just more than one kid like 10 years
ago like give us a break will ya
no like what would happen if people had
more than one kid like
what was the reason i thought i heard it
was severe fine
but they weren't they wouldn't make you
kill the kids well if you were pregnant
they made you get into forced abortions
yeah forced abortion yeah
wow but that's why they would all also
um kind of throw away or kill if the
firstborn was a daughter
yeah how long ago was this 80s like
recent
like that i i think it was even more
recent than that
but that's why they have the uh too many
mem uh
issue right now there's not enough
females
2013 yeah what what it ended in 2013.
yeah one child was a whole but no i i
heard that like
if you have money though you can have
multiple kids
you just paid the fine huh yeah oh wait
but starting in 2016 is when
all chinese couples were allowed to have
two children [ __ ] man
that's the catnip two though two child
policy now
that's crazy the shortage of uh i guess
women to marry
so then these guys are going out and um
i heard that china's colonizing africa
now so there's a lot of calling
like economically colonizing like
they're just setting up factories and
whatever and then um there it's just in
africa you see chinese letters chinese
communities
they're married malaysian babies locals
yeah there's a ton of interracial
chinese and africans i'm not surprised
there's a pattern we drone
countries and then china like settles
there
we've been joining the [ __ ] out of
africa yeah
wow it's like a resource war it's a
chinese way to go
icon
but yeah so in this article here from
the new york times they talk about how
in the 1940s barking dogs were
blamed for revealing the movements of
communist fighters who resisted japanese
occupiers during world war
ii and were branded political enemies of
the people
dogs were yeah dogs were so would like
japanese
army would bring the dogs and then or
like their own village dogs would bark
probably because they were trying to um
settle their soldiers in those villages
so they would they would make you
uh house them maybe and then the dogs
would not be down
maybe yeah i've never owned a dog
really do you like dogs do you like dogs
no i love dogs
dogs are so good i love them i love them
i really do
but my parents just we never had pets
like we never just
never begged them like you never annoyed
the [ __ ] out of them until they caved
and said all right
even as a little kid i never was really
like you know i liked just playing with
the neighbor's dog or playing with the
neighbor's cat i never was like i really
like please
no i was like i was like i need one
because i used to have one as a baby and
then like he died and [ __ ] and i need
another one
yeah did you have a cat no no pets no
nothing
you never had a relationship with the
animal no is she a one pants
she had she loved this little kitty
that she had from when she was like five
years old
to like 20 something
peaches peaches was [ __ ] a dope vlog
like just yeah pretty much yeah so it's
like
it's like a little ode to peaches
because she loved that cat and that cat
was [ __ ] tight whenever i'll go visit
chia and canada
and she would have to go like go to work
all day and do nails i would just be at
home with peaches and would be chilling
i'd be like singing a song sweet and
[ __ ] that was it like what it looked
like it was a little like you know kind
of um
orangish beige-ish um and she was cool
she was getting old too like
her her mouth was like i was like that
was like [ __ ] old like a grandma
yeah like a little grandma cat and then
when when peaches died
she was like of course super like sad
about it so now she's like no more
pets and she's like she's like i don't
want to put
our kids through the pain of like losing
a pet
so she's just like nah what about the
joys of having yeah
you know we're still it's glass half
empty [ __ ] yeah yeah i know i know
i'd be down i'd be down we're thinking
about you might as well not get married
not have kids not have love in your life
that's true yeah she she's you know
she's i think she'll get over it
eventually
the key is to have many of them a few
years ago
the key is to have many of them so if
one dies you still love the other
cats get it right
six now thank you too one of them went
away wish tiff wasn't here
[Laughter]
yeah i've always wanted a dog we adopted
one out
i put all my eggs in one dog basket and
i got devastated
after he died you don't think you'll
ever own another one
oh i want one for sure but time does not
permit for me
at this moment right that's the thing
too if i lived in a farm and i was
[ __ ] and destroying that [ __ ] and
popping out seven children
i'm gonna get animals for sure because
those [ __ ] are really good
at corralling each other true you just
let them and you get a three-year-old
baby you just like pick up that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey stop eating that [ __ ]
all right cool and you just chill there
and bark orders at all of the animals
and kids
i just pictured you [ __ ] a farm that
had a [ __ ] and i was like yeah i know
there were so many different words in
the middle of the field just [ __ ] the
hole in the ground yeah i was
a planet cats [ __ ] which ones are we
talking about
i thought she's so good he can't let go
and i'm like dude good for you
why didn't you ever have a dog tiffany
oh
um because my mom always brought
straight cats home and i'm like i don't
want
a [ __ ] cat you never just got a dog
and brought one
so there was this one time like this
very very brief moment in time
when i don't even know where the [ __ ] we
got this dog but i had a dog for like
literally a day it was only only a day
yeah and it was a puppy and it was like
barking a lot and i was just trying to
figure out how to like deal with it but
i was so
[ __ ] ecstatic because it's just like
my whole life i always wanted a dog
and then i don't know what happened but
my mom said we couldn't keep it for some
reason or something happened i don't
remember i just know i only had a dog
for a day
and someone sat on the dog no it didn't
die
like they got rid of it she also did the
same thing with a bunny like
she got me a bunny but this time it
lasted for like i think a week
ish or maybe two weeks it was a short
time too and then she gave the bunny
away
and i was like oh damn it damn why
should you keep playing with your
emotions like that i don't know i don't
know her reasoning i gotta ask her and
find out what happened she was like damn
this is
more i bit off more than i can chew i
didn't know a dog would be all this
[ __ ]
yeah probably because cats are a lot
easier and we did have
like i don't even know how many but i
remember like cycling through a lot of
different cats
at one point we had a cat that was
pregnant and then she gave birth to
kittens
and like yeah i was playing with kittens
at one point
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened then
your mom snatched them all away
apparently
only for one day
yeah it was it was a really short period
with
no but they had to be with the mom what
the [ __ ] happened to those cats
i don't know i don't know i have a cat
now
um who is my cat but i have to i can't
keep her
why yeah her name she her name
i call her mama but her she's cece is
her actual name i guess
but um she's the mom to all the kittens
that we have
and she like she like picked me like
like like i'm
i'm like i'm like her i'm her guy and so
it sucks because
she doesn't get along with our boy cats
like franklin and joe
stupid nicki's cats yeah but stupid
stupid mama doesn't
like just have any chill because she
loves her kids so much so
even if the kids haven't done anything
or like there's no strife or anything
she has to like
like front for them and i'm like oh no
mom you don't have to do this [ __ ] but
it's just not fair to them it's
stressing them the [ __ ] out so it sucks
why don't you just give her away we're
gonna have to yeah
he's bummed because that's the cat that
chose him yeah she loves me
i've never had it what does she choose
like she just always want to hang out
with her always wants to hang with me
just
she just she just spends all day rubbing
against my legs wanting me to pattern
yeah they [ __ ] like rub their faces
against you yeah
and she even gives me love bites like
she love bites my legs and [ __ ] which is
super [ __ ] jarring
you don't think eventually they'll just
get over it and and like have her
accepted because one of the three that
are part of your household is her son
yeah yeah but then i have four cats
that's a lot of cats it's a lot of cats
and then
also if they don't get along i've kept
her too long so it's just it's not fair
it sucks though it sucks i'm so so torn
up about it why don't you get a pet
hamster and let them all run
but then why why gets hit why get tom
and not
not mama if nicki already has two
i love tom too tom's great but tom
didn't pick you
well tom is very fair to both of us but
mama is just
she just loves she loves me and what
sucks is i know she's an older
cat she's like two and so she's full
grown already so a lot of people it's
not as attractive everyone wants a kid
lame so yeah i'm sorry mama oh
never meant to hurt you wow you even did
a nicki reference
eminem and cats in one thing god
that was masterful
you